deacon he's acting now i am so proud
it's really good stuff i'm i'm super
proud put your hand underneath your
chair
that is a weight sensitive explosive if
you get off that chair it detonates this
movie was was so fun and twisted in so
many weird ways it kept me guessing i
want to know from the two of you what
what drew you in all these all these
wild story lines of these couples kind
of intertwined and this is kind of a
joke and kind of not a joke but
was there any deciding factor that came
into the fact that you get to sit down
for the entire movie
that's a good question especially as you
get to be my age
no but you know one of the most
interesting things for me about this
process was that kat and i hadn't really
met or spent time around each other
until we sat down and started filming
and which was very cool
in reference to what our characters are
going through because
we really didn't know much about each
other at all before we started and so we
like kind of like it felt
very true to what our characters were
experiencing in some ways exactly yeah
we filmed it pretty much in a linear way
from the beginning of the character's
meeting up until
the end and
it actually forced us to have to really
trust each other because there were
certain things that ryan would do or
that i would do and we had to kind of
follow each other through certain beats
and not having that time ahead of time
was um in a lot of ways um like a
blessing because it forced us to really
be on our
on our toes and and we couldn't for
certain things we just had to kind of go
for it and that was really fun
yeah it was a real wild ride and i mean
your guys chemistry sitting there you
know as an actor i i was previously an
actor for about 10 years and i can only
imagine trying to carry a film from a
seated position where you can do so
little and it all has to come out here
and you guys just did such a good job
you're hanging on your every word trying
to figure out this story i just i really
liked it
ryan has everything in his eyes he
doesn't have to move a muscle and you're
just
i mean there were moments where it
wasn't even on me and he would do
scenes and i would just the camera
couldn't even see but i would be like
just bawling because he was so
incredible
i love that i love that i want to bring
this up this question is is happens in
the midst of conversation we live with
ourselves
isn't that a consequence enough
um
so interesting one that makes you think
tell me good or bad the decisions that
we make do you agree with something like
this what's your take on on that line
itself i do agree with it i agree that
we live with the consequences of
ourselves but how you
energetically take that on is what
dictates whether or not it becomes like
a noose or like a around your you know
so i think that like
you can also channel the bad things that
happen in your life for good if you if
you learn from it and if you you know
and so i i do i i don't think it has to
be as ominous or as or as
heavy as it sounds like that you can
turn those things around for good yeah
what about your cat
yeah i mean we make decisions and we
have to live with them or we are haunted
by
relationships or experiences we've had
and
they can completely envelop you or you
can use them to heal and to
be
better right yeah for sure um all right
i want to pivot a little bit there's so
many things i want to ask both of you
and we don't have a lot of time ryan i
want to talk real quick deacon and his
uh he's he's acting now i'm a father of
a seven-year-old and my son always asks
me what do i do why are you on tv this
and that but we have him and never have
i ever season three what's it like for
you to see him
both doing the music and now the acting
you must be so proud it's i i am so
proud and he's about to go to college in
new york for music and
you know and that's his primary focus
the acting thing he likes to do and he
will you know
according to what his appetite for it is
but like his focus is primarily music
and the the music he's about to he's
actually dropping a mixtape this friday
on soundcloud that's incredible and i'm
so excited for people to hear yeah
it's it's really good stuff i'm i'm
super proud dude that's awesome and real
quick i want to bring this up i know
what you did last summer 25 years ago
we're right around there what do you
what do you remember from that time
being on that movie
i mean i do remember a fair amount
because it was only my second or third
movie and i was so excited to do it
um but when you say that it's the 25th
year anniversary it just makes me feel
like a dinosaur honestly
like jesus how long have i been doing
this like
um but you know nothing but good
memories from that period of time like i
just recently saw sarah michelle and uh
um
you know we got together with for
selma's birthday recently and
um
you know it's i i i was 19 years old
when i made that movie so like it has a
lot of
young
sort of memories
related to it but uh i you know i'm i'm
happy to have done it for sure i know
what you did last summer ooh
what a crockett
we need help
yeah i'll say you know what you guys
should check out a mirror once in a
while you two look like run over twice
yeah um all right cat i wanna talk
you're almost done with this world tour
long hot summer how has it been going
what is that like for you uh it's it's
been a lot of fun i mean um
i with
ryan's son deacon and music music the
music industry is not easy they don't
make it easy for you it takes a ton of
time a ton of energy and effort and then
when you get into touring it's
physically exhausting but it it when you
connect with people and they connect to
your music and you get to perform it
it's
so awesome it's the best feeling and uh
yeah i love it i'm heading to germany
tomorrow to headline a festival so we're
just we're just going we're going it is
fun we are getting it
get after it we love to see it and i
want to talk about the song oprah rich
real quick has opened
up do you know if she's heard this
because i was just no i i hope she
hasn't in a weird way because i miss her
and she's
it's just it was a fun song to do this
so i dropped a record um in june and
it's all about
it's a partnership with glad and the
proceeds go to glad and it's all about
um
rights and lgbtq rights and being your
loudest proudest self and it's just a
super fun
pop fierce record right it's that kind
of just like let's go party
record ibiza fun and i put out a record
called oprah rich which we had
originally recorded which is something
fun to do
and it's kind of taking off um so i'm
just wondering when that conversation
with her
feels about it but to be clear being
oprah rich is not all about wealth i
mean oprah is is
spiritually wealthy she's morally
wealthy she's culturally wealthy she's
she's an abundant she represents
absolute abundance so
um that's what i mean when i say oprah
rich you can be absolutely broke broken
your bank account and still be oprah
rich
[Music]
you